speaking of emotional intelligence
you asked alina because you date other
girls stephen
why did you do that why did you ask her
that
yeah i knew you guys are gonna ask that
question yeah
and this is one of those questions that
i'm definitely gonna ask you guys to
keep watching for because we're gonna
hit on this subject i'm almost certain
so definitely check out the future
episodes but um
it's
it's kind of complicated
it's complicated well that's a good t
stephen because i want to know now i
want to know now
i mean watching
are you still open to dating other girls
is that still something you want to do
that one
you're also going to tune in door
don't break our hearts stephen don't
have us coming for you over alina
6t okay
okay when stephen asked me if he can
date other girls
i just burst into tears what if elena
asked you if she could see other men if
she gave you the same dose of medicine
that you gave her well
like that would be
good because you know we were
you know long distance
and we had never really spent very much
time together
and i
had just gone out of a relationship and
i didn't feel emotionally ready yet to
really
dive into a relationship especially with
someone as amazing as alina because i
really felt like
we had a connection and i really felt
like something
like
was different about her and i wanted to
be ready for that
so i feel like if she
wanted to i wouldn't have an issue with
it and i wouldn't ever ask her to do
something if i wasn't comfortable with
her doing it because i think uh in
relationships it's super important to be
mutually like
on the same level
one thing i still need to tell lena is
that
i am not a virgin and that i've had
sexual relationships in the past you're
mormon and
along with asking alina to convert you
two decided to stay pure until marriage
the only problem with that is that
you're not pure you didn't tell her the
truth about you not being a virgin why
weren't you honest
i don't think
not honest is the right terminology here
it's just something that didn't like
come up necessarily but do you think
that that's fair though that she has
because she has this idea as where we
are in the show that both of you are
pure and you're saving yourselves for
marriage did you know she had that idea
in her head and you just didn't correct
it i'm not sure i knew at the time that
she
that's something she really valued you
know i think on a lot of these topics
it's kind of very vulnerable topics and
it's not something that
i feel
i normally talk about right
you know most of the time we're calling
and talking we didn't hit upon those
subjects necessarily you know i don't so
are you saying that she
assumed it wasn't it wasn't a
conversation that you two had about
staying pure is that what you're saying
um
what i'm saying is that i usually when i
call and talk with people i usually
don't tell them how many people i've
slept with
so
so that's kind of uh with elena that's
just something we never
brought up
she has an assumption
that you're a virgin
yes
no i don't i don't know that's what she
said she told her friends we both
decided to stay pure until we get
married so she got that idea from
somewhere i mean i think it's because i
do like i honestly like a very i think
um
sexuality should be something special
and i think that
and i think that's the way i always talk
about it is there's something sacred and
because of that i think that kind of
led her to believe perhaps okay well let
me ask you this would you still want to
be with elena if she wasn't a virgin
yeah i mean i i love her and i don't
feel like
as long as she
is
who she is that's cool
i think the
hardest thing about that whole situation
was that i was like one of the first
really believing people elena had met
who kind of lives by like a set standard
not so much an arbitrary standard
because of that
i think sometimes believing people or
people who
[Music]
acclaim certain values sometimes are
held to a higher standard which isn't
necessarily fair because they're still
people too
the reason i think it was so hard
to talk about the subject is because i
don't want to let her down and i don't
want to be
the reason why she would perhaps stop
believing because a lot of people
take these things like personally and
they feel like oh well if this believing
person doesn't live up to his beliefs
that's true
then like why should i believe like why
does that help me so i think the hardest
part for me
is i'm afraid that she's gonna
see kind of how i didn't live up to the
standards and then kind of be like
oh well maybe
you know
the whole church thing isn't worth it
and then obviously
i wouldn't feel comfortable
marrying someone who wasn't ready to
live in the church with me so yeah
i think you said something really
interesting because online i have seen
that people call you hypocritical
because they feel as if you play certain
standards on elena and you don't follow
those same standards but i think you
made a good point i mean the point of
religion
is to help us stay on the straight and
narrow but because we're human none of
us are perfect
right
um so that's why we have a practice to
help us you know
stay on the right track so what do you
say to those people by the way the ones
who feel as if you're being hypocritical
yeah i think this is like jesus said it
best when he says um
you know he who is among you without sin
let him first cast the stone
so i think you know all these people
obviously
i so many people you know have so many
opinions and that's just what they are
they're just opinions and you know my
own
beliefs and my own opinions are my own
and i am fortunate i can have whatever
opinions that i want to have i'm
currently a student and i study chinese
language and asian politics how do you
feel knowing that alina she put her
dreams her college path on hold
to be with you
in turkey does that add any pressure for
you to make sure this thing works do you
feel any guilt it has a ton of pressure
especially
people of the lds faith obviously
education is huge for us one of our past
prophets president hinckley he has a
huge emphasis on you know education so
i'm definitely aware that you know that
was a huge sacrifice on her and to come
and be with me
and it makes me
kind of it makes me like i don't know
proud of myself in some ways that she
cares about me enough to do that but at
the same time you know there's a lot of
responsibility can viewers expect a
marriage between you and elena is that
something that we can look forward to
this season that
is such a great question because
i can say honestly that
from when
and where the show started and like
just like seeing it and like remembering
what it was like to be in that moment
and then to go
forward to now like i would have never
guessed everything that happened and
it's scary
and i'm really nervous for my mom to see
yeah i might tell her to skip my parts
like mom don't watch don't watch my
parts
you know so you can watch smitt and
jenny and she can watch kenny and
armando she can watch blind accord just
like skip my parts
why what can you tease i know you can't
tell us a lot but is there is she gonna
be disappointed is it gonna be
inappropriate what
okay
let me i can't say a lot obviously but i
can't take this that
every
episode
is going to leave me personally at the
edge of my seat because i'm gonna be
there's so many different aspects to our
story line that i
don't know
which parts are gonna choose to
highlight so i'm like so nervous i'm
like i'm like
what are you what are they gonna show
this week because
as you know
i sometimes do things and then
um
it turns out to be like really weird i
guess
until like after it happens and i'm like
oh my gosh i'm so weird stephen do you
know who georgie is
from darcy and stacy have you seen
georgie
i don't know who george is no well you
if you are giving his hair a run for its
money do you ever see yourself cutting
it or no is it are you growing it for
now um well actually elena is the one
who wanted me to grow it out initially
yeah i've never really
grown it past the like once i started
getting my eyes i'd always cut it but
now i'm actually really liking it and
i'm really surprised because as i'm
getting older it's actually getting like
a little more fuller and thicker
yeah
and this is my first time having long
hair so it's really fun and it helps me
understand i think a lot of women or
other
blind people hair
more because
like the other day i got a drink from a
drinking fountain for the first time
with long hair and i didn't think about
it yeah like my hair just got all wet
and i'm like oh my gosh
you